[Music]
hey friends and welcome back for another
guitar tip today's tip is a great way
for guitarists playing in any style
really to open your mind up to new
possibilities on the instrument today is
all about using alternate tunings on the
guitar
[Music]
regardless of what type of guitar you
play classical electric gypsy jazz
flamenco you know you name it you
probably use what's called standard
tuning standard tuning on a guitar is
e-a-d-g-b-e
for hundreds of years whether you're
playing music by the beatles uh
metallica all the way back to the 19th
century fernando soar you're probably
using this standard tuning and it's
probably standard for a reason right you
know we didn't end up here by accident
we ended up here through a lot of trial
and error and there were certainly many
different tuning systems which existed
before this standard tuning system
this instrument here is what the guitar
looked like in the 17th century this is
the baroque guitar and basically this
evolved directly into the guitar that we
all know and love today here we have an
interesting tuning we don't have the low
e string but we do have a d g b e but
even those strings are not normal you
know we have first of all double strings
um for most of them and then we have on
the d string
a high d and a low d
which play at the same time
then for the a the fifth string which
should be
with the lowest note so far actually it
goes up the octave
so this is a reentrant tuning so the
guitar that we all know today the ead
gbe tuning definitely wasn't always the
standard tuning
but let's get back to the modern guitar
this standard tuning evolved because it
really works it really works for
composing music it really works for
playing chords it's a good one but
i often feel as a player as an
improviser as an occasional composer i
feel that if we only play in standard
tuning we find ourselves limited in
certain ways meaning that inherent to
the tuning there are certain chord
shapes and voicings which are going to
work better than others and with
hundreds of years of music behind this
tuning obviously this one is good but it
doesn't mean we can't alter a string or
two to open up some new possibilities in
today's guitar tip i'm going to show you
how to use alternate tunings on the
guitar to perhaps inspire you to play
the instrument in a new way
[Music]
the first alternate tuning that
guitarists learn is drop d this is where
we take the low e string and we just
simply drop it down
how far a whole step
down until it matches
the fourth string d of course this is
one octave apart you can really tune
this well if you play the harmonic on
the sixth string and then the open d
if it's a little off
you'll hear beats wow
and you want to get those beats to go
away
like that that would be that would mean
you're in tune
this is called drop d and in drop d one
of the reasons it sounds so good is
because we have d a d
as our low three strings on the bases
and actually i came to know this tuning
really well because we used this tuning
in my metal band
this idea of playing an open power chord
is what it is
on the low bass strings so you can
really play great metal music on this
tuning
yeah
so if you're playing punk metal or rock
uh if you just lay your fingers down
over the bases in a bar chord you can
just slide them around
and and everything you do you'll find
out there are certain threats fractures
sound good so the good frets to play for
example a minor scale would be 0 2 3 5 7
8
and you could just invent some nice
music on those
[Music]
so easy to play something really heavy
you know if you want to play something
in a lighter style with some perhaps
some finger picking this is also great
tuning because it means that if you play
for example with your thumb on the low
bases here the bottom three strings you
can just pluck any of those strings
anytime you want and they make a nice
open d chord
and this allows your other fingers to
play a melody on top so for example if
we play a d minor scale on the first two
strings we'll play d the third fret of
the second string
open e
f the first fret
g the third fret if we just keep to
those frets there
we can improvise
utilizing this open d tuning
[Music]
if we go up a little higher we play
the fifth fret and sixth fret on the
first string it can get even more
beautiful
[Music]
so really all i'm doing here is i'm
randomly
plucking these bass strings with my
thumb and just playing
notes that work in that scale you can
make it major by using frets 0 2
3 5
7 instead and still this first d
[Music]
the next alternate tuning i want to
suggest is what i call drop g
so in this case we play the fifth string
a and we're going to make it sound just
like the g string but an octave lower so
same ideas drop d
now we have d
g
d
g
this tuning is fantastic for playing in
g major or g minor uh in g major
especially because now
the bottom five strings are a g major
chord
d g d g
b natural that's a g major chord and
that leaves the first string open so on
the first string if we use frets 0 2 3 5
7 8 10
12. any of those frets in any order with
these open strings we're gonna get some
beautiful sounds
[Music]
for the next tuning let's bring our
fifth string back to a
um now we have d a d again so now we're
back to drop d tuning from here i like
to change the third string down to f
sharp it's a half step below we can play
the f sharp
on the first string second fret
and make that match
[Music]
if you want the same exact note you can
play the fourth fret on the fourth
string
to make sure it matches now when you do
this
now we have a d a d f sharp chord that's
a d major chord there's a lot you could
do there but let's go really extreme
with this one let's take our second
string down to
a
[Music]
and our first string down to g
[Music]
this means our entire guitar is one big
d major chord because we have d a d
f sharp
a
d so you have three ds
and two a's
it's a really thick sounding chord you
could also make this one minor
if you just take the third string down
to f sharp we'll stay in major
there's no way you can sound bad in this
tuning
everything sounds fantastic
you can finger pick you can strum
when you finger pick you can just hop
your thumb around
you can add a bit of percussion
[Music]
by slapping
that sixth string you could dabble with
some harmonics at the 12th fret
the 7th fret or the 5th fret which all
sound amazing now because they're all
beautiful chords
[Music]
and of course you can play bigger chords
too if you
bar the fifth fret
bar the seventh fret those are our
one chord four chord
v chord
[Music]
and if we can bar those chords we can
actually free up our other fingers to do
more music
[Music]
do
[Music]
so those are just a few examples but i
assure you the rabbit hole goes much
deeper than that
start experimenting what happens if you
just change a string a half step off how
does that change the way you play how
does that change the way you think about
the fretboard you don't even need to
know what notes you're playing just see
what type of new resonances emerge from
your instrument so have fun
experimenting with these fun alternate
tunings by the way if you enjoyed this
free video you can give back to me by
subscribing or liking this video and if
you really would like to help my channel
you can head to my patreon where you'll
find many extra guitar tips only
available there as well as lots of other
behind the scenes features and other
perks
so thanks for watching and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you